Hello everyone and welcome to The Rest is History and welcome to St. Bartholomew the Great, which is London's oldest medieval church and a very appropriate setting for what is a new mini-series for club members. As a massive treat and because on The Rest is History, we are all heart. We are making this first episode free. If you like it and you would like to see the next two, then you need to. know what you've got to do. It's an appropriate setting because the theme of this mini-series is the real-life Circe Lannisters, the She-Wolves of medieval England. And with me to talk about the She-Wolves is the author of a book called She-Wolves. It's my dear friend and erstwhile colleague, Helen Kaster, Helen, welcome to the rest of history. Thank you for having me. Before we go to the Middle Ages, should we just look at the century that follows the medieval period, the 16th century, because there are a lot of queens in the 16th century.
大家好，欢迎收听《历史的其余部分》，欢迎来到大圣巴托罗姆教堂。这是伦敦最古老的修道院教堂，作为俱乐部会员全新迷你剧的背景再合适不过了。为了回馈大家，也因为我们在《历史的其余部分》中充满爱心，我们将免费提供第一集。如果你喜欢并想观看接下来的两集，那你得知道该怎么做。这个背景非常合适，因为本迷你剧的主题是现实生活中的瑟曦·兰尼斯特——中世纪英格兰的母狼们。和我一起谈论母狼们的是一本名为《母狼》的书的作者，我亲爱的朋友、昔日的同事海伦·卡斯特。海伦，欢迎来到《历史的其余部分》。谢谢邀请我。在我们进入中世纪之前，我们是不是应该先看看中世纪之后的那个世纪，即16世纪，因为16世纪有很多女王。
And what perspective do all those queens kind of shed on the time that we're going to be talking about today on the series? It's interesting, isn't it, because it goes in two directions. In one sense, we tend to assume, I think, that because there are all these queens in the 16th century. So should we just list them? So Elizabeth I first, Mary Queen of Scots, Mary Tudor. There's also, there's this extraordinary moment in the 1550s where there seem to be women everywhere. A monstrous regiment, you might say. A monstrous regiment of women, although Knox doesn't quite mean that.
所有这些女王对我们今天在这个系列中要谈论的时代有什么样的启发呢？这很有趣，不是吗？因为它是双向的。从某种意义上说，我认为我们往往会假设，因为在16世纪有这么多女王。那我们是不是该列举一下她们呢？首先是伊丽莎白一世、苏格兰女王玛丽、玛丽·都铎。还有，在16世纪50年代有一个非同寻常的时期，似乎到处都是女性。你可以说是一个荒谬的政权。一个由女性组成的荒谬政权，尽管诺克斯的意思并非完全如此。
We'll come to that. Mary of Hungary has been ruling the Netherlands for her. Is that all Mary? They're all Mary's for her brother, the Holy Roman Emperor Charles V. Mary Queen of Scots is the Queen of Scotland living in Paris, while her mother, Mary of Gies, is regent in Scotland for her. Then we have Mary Tudor in England. They're all Marys.
我们等会儿会谈到这一点。匈牙利玛丽一直在为她的哥哥、神圣罗马帝国皇帝查理五世统治着尼德兰。这都是玛丽吗？她们怎么都是玛丽？为了她的哥哥神圣罗马帝国皇帝查理五世。苏格兰女王玛丽是住在巴黎的苏格兰女王，而她的母亲吉斯的玛丽则在苏格兰担任她的摄政。然后我们在英格兰有玛丽·都铎。她们都叫玛丽。
They're all Catholic. And in Geneva, John Knox, a fulminating Calvinist, Scott with a big beard, is extremely cross about all this. So he writes the first blast of the trumpet against the monstrous regiment of women saying... And the monstrous regiment is not like a kind of military parade of queens kind of marching, It's easy to see, isn't it, this dreadful battalion of Mary's? No. Regiment means regimen rule and monstrous means unnatural, abominable. So what he's talking about is the monstrous rule of women which he thinks shouldn't be allowed. His timing is terrible. He publishes this in the summer of 1558. A few months later, Protestant Elizabeth becomes Queen in England. She's not impressed. She never forgives him, that she? She's left saying, I didn't.
她们都是天主教徒。而在日内瓦，约翰·诺克斯，一位愤怒的加尔文主义苏格兰人，留着大胡子，对此感到极其恼火。于是他写了《反对女性怪物政权的号角初鸣》，说道……这个怪物政权可不是像某种阅兵式似的女王游行，很容易看出来，不是吗，这支可怕的玛丽营？不。政权（Regiment）在这里指的是统治，而怪物（Monstrous）在这里指的是不自然、可憎。所以他谈论的是女性的可憎统治，他认为这是不被允许的。他的时机糟透了。他在1558年夏天发表了这篇东西。几个月后，新教徒伊丽莎白在英格兰成为女王。她对此并不买账。她从未原谅过他，对吧？她留下一句话说，我指的不是
mean you, but she never forgives him quite rightly. But we tend to assume that if this argument is going on in the 16th century, that women are beginning to rule but there's a big pushback, that this must be progress, because we tend to think of the Middle Ages as sort of benighted. Things were obviously worse then, less woke in the Middle Ages, but it's not necessarily true. The point being that in the middle of the 16th century, it's really the accident of the hereditary system that's thrown all these women into the century. It's Henry VIII's famous inability to father a son until he does and then the son dies and he's just got these two daughters.
你，但她从未原谅过他，这是完全可以理解的。但我们往往会假设，如果这种争论在16世纪正在进行，即女性开始统治但遭到了强烈的反对，这一定是一种进步，因为我们往往认为中世纪是黑暗的。当时的情况显然更糟，中世纪时没有那么“觉醒”，但这并不一定是真的。关键在于，在16世纪中期，把所有这些女性推入这个世纪的，实际上只是世袭制度的一个意外。这就是亨利八世著名的无法生下一个儿子，直到他生了一个，然后这个儿子死了，而他只剩下了这两个女儿。
That's right. But also his great skill at killing anyone else on the family tree who might have a better claim than the Tudors. So he's killed lots of potential male heirs and only been left with these two daughters. But the hereditary principle could have thrown up women at any point in the centuries before. and in fact it had done back in the 12th century. So should we go to that? Yes, let's do that.
没错。但这也归功于他非常擅长杀掉家族树上任何其他可能比都铎家族更有继承权的人。所以他杀了很多潜在的男性继承人，只留下了这两个女儿。但在前几个世纪的任何时候，世袭原则本都可能让女性登上权力宝座，事实上，早在12世纪就已经发生过了。那我们要不要转到那个话题？好的，我们这就讲。
And I've said that we're in London's oldest parish church. And this was originally part of a priory that was founded in the reign of Henry I by Henry the first jester. And Henry the first is the son of William the Conqueror. So we're going right the way back, you know, a very, very long way. And Matilda is the daughter of Henry the first, isn't she? She is the granddaughter of. of the Conqueror. And what we need to understand about this moment in English history
我刚才说过，我们身处伦敦最古老的教区教堂。这里原本是一个小修道院的一部分，由亨利一世统治时期的亨利一世的弄臣建立。亨利一世是征服者威廉的儿子。所以我们要一直追溯到很久很久以前。而玛蒂尔达是亨利一世的女儿，对吧？她确实是征服者的孙女。我们需要了解英格兰历史上的这个关键时刻
is that really all bets are off about what the system of succession is going to be. There hasn't actually been yet, by the time we get to Henry I and Matilda, there hasn't yet been a straightforward succession since the Conqueror. The Conqueror himself was illegitimate. His parents hadn't been married. He does get married and has sons, but he's succeeded by William Rufus, who's his second son, even though his oldest son, Robert Kurt Hoze, as he's known, Robert short legs, Robert fat legs, depending how rude you want to get.
实际上，关于继承制度将是怎样的，一切都还是未知数。事实上，到了亨利一世和玛蒂尔达的时候，自征服者以来，还没有过一次直接的顺利继承。征服者本人是私生子，他的父母并没有结婚。他后来结了婚并有了儿子，但继承他的是他的次子威廉·鲁弗斯，尽管他的长子是被称为“短腿罗伯特”或“胖腿罗伯特”的罗伯特·柯托斯，这取决于你想怎么粗鲁地称呼他。
He's the eldest son, but he's not the one who ends up inheriting. Well, he inherits England, doesn't he, and Robert inherits Normandy. In theory. So this is a complication. In theory. You're absolutely right. We're dealing not only with a new system in England, but a new political entity, the Anglo-Norman realm, which is two different parts. It's the Duchy of Normandy and the Kingdom of England.
他是长子，但最终继承王位的不是他。嗯，他继承了英格兰，对吧，而罗伯特继承了诺曼底。理论上是这样的。所以这是一个复杂的情况。理论上是。你完全说得对。我们不仅要面对英格兰的一个新系统，还要面对一个新的政治实体——盎格鲁-诺曼领地，它由两个不同的部分组成：诺曼底公国和英格兰王国。
William tries to split them up. He's already promised Normandy to his oldest son, who he's gone off since doing that. But he really wants Rufus to inherit, and Rufus fights Robert and gets the whole lot. But in the New Forest, August 1100, an arrow goes astray, William Rufus gets speared in the heart. Robert, the older brother, is still alive, but Henry the younger brother is the one who's there, seizes his moment. He jumps on his horse, looking at the prone body of his brother, shot by an arrow in the New Forest, and rushes to Westminster to get himself crowned and rushes to Winchester to take control of royal treasury. So he's king by a coup, really, rather than by I'm the eldest, I should inherit.
威廉试图把它们分离开。他已经把诺曼底承诺给了他的长子，尽管他后来对这样做感到后悔。但他真的很想让鲁弗斯继承，鲁弗斯与罗伯特作战并占有了全部。但在1100年8月的荒野新森林里，一支箭射偏了，威廉·鲁弗斯的心脏被射中。长兄罗伯特仍然在世，但身为弟弟的亨利当时就在现场，他抓住了时机。他跳上马，看着倒在血泊中、被新森林里的箭射中的哥哥的尸体，急忙赶往威斯敏斯特为自己加冕，并急忙赶往温彻斯特控制皇家金库。所以他当上国王实际上是通过政变，而不是凭着“我是长子，我应该继承”的原则。
Can I ask? You say he's crowned, but he's also anointed. And there's a kind of, there I say, sacral dimension to that. That once he's been anointed, I mean, you can't really wash off the balm. That's it. And that's what makes a king at this point. It is, as you say, it's a quasi-sacrament. kingship takes effect in that holy moment. We tend to say crowned, but you're quite right to point at the moment when the holy oil touches the head, the breast. That is when a king becomes a king. And Henry is incredibly able, and he marries into the old Anglo-Saxon royal dynasty, so he has gained himself legitimacy in that way.
我能问一下吗？你说他加冕了，但他也是受过涂油礼的。其中有一种，恕我直言，神圣的维度。一旦他受了涂油礼，我的意思是，你真的洗不掉那圣膏。就是这样。这就是当时造就国王的原因。正如你所说，这是一种准圣礼。王权在那个神圣的时刻生效。我们倾向于说加冕，但你指出圣油接触头部和胸部的时刻是非常正确的。那才是国王成为国王的时刻。亨利极其能干，他与古代盎格鲁-Saxon王室联姻，从而以这种方式获得了合法性。
He has legitimacy in all sorts of ways. He's also very keen to point out that he was born in the purple. That is, he was born after William the Conqueror became King of England. He's married Matilda of Scotland, the daughter of St Margaret of Scotland, who's descended from the Anglo-Saxon royal house. You've got a saint as your mother-in-law. I mean, that's pretty good, isn't it? It is.
他在方方面面都具有合法性。他也非常急于指出自己是“生于紫衣”之中的。也就是说，他是在征服者威廉成为英格兰国王之后出生的。他娶了苏格兰的玛蒂尔达，她是苏格兰圣玛格丽特的女儿，圣玛格丽特是盎格鲁-萨克森王室的后代。你的岳母是一位圣人。我的意思是，这相当不错，不是吗？确实如此。
So he's a very able king, and he does what kings are meant to do, which is to father children, and in particular a son. So just tell us about his children. Henry is an interesting character. He has many, many, many children. He has at least 20 illegitimate children, although one of his fans among the chroniclers says with a completely straight face that this was not a question of lust.
所以他是一位非常能干的国王，他做着国王应该做的事情，那就是生儿育女，特别是生个儿子。那么跟我们讲讲他的孩子吧。亨利是一个有趣的人物。他有很多很多孩子。他至少有20个私生子，尽管他的一位编年史家崇拜者面不改色地宣称，这并非出于欲望。
This was a question of, I can't remember quite what it was a question of, but clearly it was something very holy and kingly. But he only has two legitimate children. He has a son, William, and a daughter, Matilda, and he's got big plans for both of them. So William is called William Atheling, and Athaling is the old English word for someone who is, worthy to succeed to the throne. And it's a purely masculine signifier. It is. A female
这关乎于，我记不太清这究竟关乎什么了，但显然这是一件非常神圣且具有王者风范的事情。但他只有两个合法的孩子。他有一个儿子威廉和一个女儿玛蒂尔达，他对这两人都有宏伟的计划。所以威廉被称为威廉·阿瑟林（William Atheling），而阿瑟林是古英语中对有资格继承王位的人的称呼。这是一个纯粹的男性标志。确实如此。女性的
equivalent. There is not. And you can see why when you look at the great seal of the new Norman Kings of England, because the two central roles of kingship are depicted there. On one side, you have a king sitting on a throne with the symbols of kingship, an orb, sometimes a sword, sometimes a sceptive. This is a king as lawgiver as judge. And on the other side, you have a king in armour on a horse with a sword in his hand, king as warrior. Those are the two central functions and neither of them is something that a woman can do. So we've got the Atheling, William. Let's come to Matilda, the daughter.
对应词是没有的。当你查看英格兰新诺曼国王的大国玺时，你就会明白其中的原因，因为王权的两个核心角色都在上面得到了描绘。在一面，你看到一个国王坐在王座上，带着王权的象征，一个宝球，有时是一把剑，有时是一根权杖。这是一个作为立法者和法官的国王。而在另一面，你看到一个国王身穿盔甲骑在马上，手里拿着剑，这是一个作为战士的国王。这两个是核心职能，女性都无法做到。所以我们有了阿瑟林威廉。接下来我们谈谈女儿玛蒂尔达。
So what role does Henry see her fulfilling? A huge, dynastic role because he secures for her the grandest possible husband in At the age of eight, she is sent off to Germany to marry the Holy Roman Emperor, Henry V. So she becomes Empress? She does. She is not actually eventually crowned by the Pope, but she is crowned in St. Peter's in Rome by a bishop. Of course...
那么亨利希望她扮演什么角色呢？一个巨大的王朝角色，因为他为她安排了最显赫的丈夫。在八岁时，她被送往德国，嫁给神圣罗马帝国皇帝亨利五世。所以她成了皇后？是的。她最终其实并没有由教皇加冕，但她在罗马的圣彼得大教堂由一位主教加冕。当然……
That's good enough, isn't it? She calls herself Empress for the rest of her life. She's married to the emperor. She has been crowned in St. Peters. I mean, this is an extraordinary destiny. If you imagine being an eight-year-old girl. sent off across Europe to a country where you don't speak the language, you're marrying a man 16 years older than you.
这已经足够好了，不是吗？她余生都自称为皇后。她嫁给了皇帝。她曾在圣彼得大教堂加冕。我的意思是，这是一场非同寻常的命运。如果你想象一下自己是一个八岁的小女孩。被送到横跨欧洲的异国他乡，那里的人你语言不通，你要嫁给一个比你大16岁的男人。
It's a big ask. It's a huge ask. And she makes a tremendous success of it. She is known in Germany thereafter as the good Matilda. By the age of 16, she has the confidence of her husband to such an extent that he leaves her behind in Italy as his regent when he is called back to Germany. She is extraordinarily able and she takes on this job to which she's been sent when she's a child with such aplom and such ability. So what that suggests is that although queens aren't expected to fight or to deliver judgment, they do definitely have a role to play.
这要求太高了。要求太高了。而她把这件事做得极为成功。此后她在德国被称为“好玛蒂尔达”。到了16岁时，她赢得了丈夫的高度信任，以至于当他被召回德国时，他把她留在意大利作为自己的摄政。她极其能干，她以极大的从容和能力承担了这份她在童年时就被派去的工作。所以这表明，尽管人们不指望女王去打仗或做出判决，但她们确实有要扮演的角色。
They do. They can represent the men to whom they are related, to whom they are supposed to be, a supplemental figure. And I mean supplemental in two ways. That is, they must acknowledge male authority, but they can supplement it. They can represent it when it is unquestionable that they have the right to do so. So Matilda, as the emperor's wife, can represent him when he's not there, but they must do so in a way that accords with what it is to be a good woman. So I've said we're in St. Bartholomew the Great. This is the place where the Virgin Mary made her only recorded appearance in London. And I'm wondering, does the model of the Virgin
她们确实有。她们可以代表与她们有血缘关系的、她们本应成为其补充的男性形象。我这里的“补充”包含两层意思。也就是说，她们必须承认男性的权威，但她们可以对其进行补充。当她们拥有不容置疑的权利时，她们可以代表这种权威。因此，作为皇帝的妻子，玛蒂尔达可以在皇帝不在时代表他，但她们必须以符合一个好女人标准的方式来行事。我刚才说过我们身处大圣巴托罗姆教堂。这是圣母玛利亚在伦敦唯一一次有据可查的显灵之地。我在想，中世纪欧洲的圣母模式——圣母，你知道的，你可以向圣母祈祷，让她向她的儿子基督代求——其中是否有某种元素影响了女王的角色，即她可以为人们向身为国王的丈夫代求？
in medieval Europe, the Virgin, you know, you can pray to the Virgin to intercede with her son, Christ, is there an element of that that influences the role of the Queen that she can intercede for people with her husband, the king? Certainly. She must be a peacemaker, an intercessor. She can represent his authority and impose his authority, but she must never challenge it. Because as St. Paul tells us in the first letter to the Corinthians, Christ is the head of man, man is the head of woman, and God is the head of Christ. So there is an order of creation here in which women must acknowledge male authority.
当然。她必须是一位和平缔造者和代求者。她可以代表他的权威并施加他的权威，但她绝不能挑战权威。因为正如圣保罗在给哥林多人的第一封信中所告诉我们的那样，基督是男人的头，男人是女人的头，而上帝是基督的头。因此，这里存在着一种创造秩序，女性必须在其中承认男性的权威。
And as the Virgin does, can intercede, can make peace. But challenge must not step outside that virtuous role. A good woman wouldn't step outside that role. And therefore, a woman who does step outside that role cannot be good. Yeah. So Henry I, he's in England. He's looking very proudly at his two children. and he's got William Atheling, he's great, he's going to be a great king, he's got Matilda,
正如圣母所做的那样，可以代求，可以缔造和平。但挑战绝不能跨出那个贤淑的角色之外。一个好女人是不会跨出那个角色的。因此，一个跨出那个角色的女人就不可能是好女人。是的。所以亨利一世身在英格兰。他非常骄傲地看着他的两个孩子，他有威廉·阿瑟林，他很棒，将会成为一个伟大的国王；他有玛蒂尔达，
who's often in the empire doing her thing, you know, behaving like a queen should, all look splendid. And then there's a disaster, isn't it? And it involves, we've been doing the Lusitania, we've done the Titanic, this is another ship that sinks, and this is called the White Ship. We're in November 1120. Henry and his son William Athling are crossing from Normandy, or our about to cross from Normandy to England. This is a crossing that they do regularly. You have to do it if you're ruling both Normandy and England. Compared to Matilda, who's been crossing the Alps to get from Germany to Italy.
她经常在帝国里做她该做的事，你知道的，表现得像个王后应有的样子，一切看起来都光彩照人。然后灾难就降临了，不是吗？这涉及到——我们聊过卢西塔尼亚号，聊过泰坦尼克号，这是另一艘沉没的船，名字叫“白船”。时间是1120年11月。亨利和他的儿子威廉·阿瑟林正从诺曼底横渡海峡，或者正准备从诺曼底横渡到英格兰。这是他们经常进行的一次横渡。如果你统治着诺曼底和英格兰，你必须这么做。相比之下，玛蒂尔达则是一直在翻越阿尔卑斯山，从德国去往意大利。
One modern historian says that crossing the channel really was a matter of complete convenience compared to crossing the Alps in the Middle Ages. But something's gone wrong with the plan on this particular dark night in November. and it's the fact that William Athling, all his friends and everyone on board the ship he's travelling in is roaring drunk. Yeah, it's just a kind of massive stag do. It is. Lads on tour. Exactly.
一位现代历史学家说，与中世纪翻越阿尔卑斯山相比，横渡海峡简直是极其便利的事。但在11月这个特别黑暗的夜晚，计划出了问题。原因在于，威廉·阿瑟林、他所有的朋友以及他船上的所有人都酩酊大醉。是的，这就像是一场大型的单身派对。确实如此。小伙子们在狂欢。完全正确。
They crash into a rock or whatever. And they decide they're going to race the king's ship and they don't see the rock in Barfleur harbour. The ship goes down with all hands except we're told a butcher from Rouen who has got on board to try and get the aristocrats to pay the debts they owe him. And because he's wearing sheepskin, not silks and furs, he manages to cling on to a spa to tell someone what's happened. So this is terrible news for Henry, because who's going to succeed him? All he's got left of his legitimate children. He has all these illegitimate children. But by now, we're in, we're a couple of decades into the 12th century, and the church is beginning to get quite fierce.
他们的船撞上了暗礁。他们决定和国王的船赛跑，结果没有看到巴勒弗尔港的暗礁。船上所有人随船沉没，不过据我们所知，有一个来自鲁昂的屠夫上了船，试图让贵族们支付他们欠他的债务。因为他穿的是羊皮，而不是丝绸和皮草，他设法抓住了一根船桁，把发生的事情告诉了别人。这对亨利来说是个可怕的消息，因为谁来继承他的王位呢？他合法的孩子只剩下这些了。他有很多私生子。但到了这个时候，我们已经进入了12世纪的头几十年，教会开始变得相当严厉。
Right, his winning the conqueror was a bastard, you said. Exactly. But things have moved on. The things have moved on. Two things have moved on, particularly the church. is beginning to get quite fierce about the sacrament of marriage and cracking down on the idea of legitimate birth. But the other is that Henry I first is a classic poacher-turned gamekeeper.
没错，征服者威廉是个私生子，你刚才说过。正是如此。但情况已经变了。情况确实变了。两件事发生了变化，尤其是教会开始对婚姻圣礼变得相当严厉，并开始严厉打击非婚生子的观念。但另一件事是，亨利一世是个典型的由偷猎者变成的守林人。
Don't do as I did, do as I say. And what he says is that his bloodline, his legitimate bloodline must succeed. But the problem he's left with is he's only got a daughter left. How does he try and finesse things so that his daughter can succeed him? It's a multi-pronged plan. The first is he gets married again immediately. He's a widower by this stage, but he marries a very young woman called Adelisa Rivinuven.
不要照我做的那样做，照我说的去做。而他所说的是，他的血脉，他合法的血脉必须继承王位。但他面临的问题是，他只剩下一个女儿了。他如何巧妙地处理事情，以便让他的女儿继承他的王位呢？这是一个多管齐下的计划。首先，他立刻再次结婚。在这个阶段他已经是个鳏夫了，但他娶了一个非常年轻的女子，名叫阿德丽莎·德·洛万。
And it takes her with him everywhere. So his plan A is he's going to have more sons. Doesn't actually happen, but that's his plan A. Plan B is his daughter, Matilda, is going to be his safety net. and particularly after 1125, because five years of this second marriage, no baby sons have appeared yet. But Matilda's husband, the Holy Roman Emperor, dies. He dies very young and he and Matilda have not had any children. So she can now come back. She can now come back. She is summoned back immediately.
而且他去哪儿都带着她。所以他的A计划是生更多的儿子。虽然这并没有发生，但那是他的A计划。B计划是他的女儿玛蒂尔达将成为他的安全网，特别是在1125年之后，因为这场二次婚姻已经五年了，还没有小王子出生。但玛蒂尔达的丈夫，神圣罗马帝国皇帝去世了。他英年早逝，他和玛蒂尔达没有过任何孩子。所以她现在可以回来了。她现在可以回来了。她立刻被召回了。
And Henry has two plans for her. The first is that all of his nobles must immediately swear allegiance to Matilda as his heir. which, and this is the interesting thing, Henry VIII could have taken note of this, they immediately line up to do. Nobody says, nobody puts on a big beard and says, like John Knox, it is an atrocious idea that, you know, an abomination against nature. There's no kind of rule that says that a woman can't succeed. There are no rules at all. I mean, the fact that the Conqueror has been succeeded by his two younger sons while his oldest son is still alive, the Conqueror was basest, had born, rules are not really there at all, let alone set in stone in this world. So Henry is
亨利为她制定了两个计划。第一个计划是，他所有的贵族必须立即向玛蒂尔达宣誓效忠，承认她是他的继承人。而有趣的是，亨利八世本可以借鉴这一点，他们立刻排队这么做了。没有人说，没有人留着大胡子，像约翰·诺克斯那样说这是一个极其荒谬的想法，你知道的，这是对自然的亵渎。没有任何规则说女性不能继承王位。根本没有任何规则。我的意思是，征服者在大儿子仍然活着的时候，是由他的两个小儿子继承王位的，征服者是私生子出生，这个世界上的规则根本不存在，更不用说刻在石头上了。所以亨利正在
creating rules around him. He gets all his nobles to line up and swear allegiance to Matilda. And the only argument that breaks out is about who should have the honour of swearing first. There's an argument between his illegitimate son, Robert Earl of Gloucester, and his favourite nephew, Stephen Count of Mortain, about who's going to have the honour of. of kneeling to swear allegiance to Matilda. So, so far so good, Henry's still hoping to have more sons, his nobles have sworn allegiance to Matilda and his plan C, or perhaps could become a plan B, is that he's going to marry Matilda off again, and perhaps she can have sons so that he could be succeeded by a grandson.
在他周围建立规则。他让所有的贵族排队向玛蒂尔达宣誓效忠。唯一爆发的争论是谁应该享有率先宣誓的荣誉。他的私生子格洛斯特伯爵罗伯特和他最喜欢的侄子莫坦伯爵斯蒂芬之间产生了争执，争论谁将获得向玛蒂尔达跪下宣誓效忠的荣誉。所以，目前一切顺利，亨利仍然希望有更多的儿子，他的贵族们已经向玛蒂尔达宣誓效忠，而他的C计划，或者可能会成为B计划，就是把玛蒂尔达再次嫁出去，也许她可以生儿子，这样他就可以由一个孙子来继承王位。
And is there someone suitable to marry, perhaps from the French house. there is. Injou, which is Normandy's next-door neighbour, historic adversary and rival, but there is a young heir to the county of Anjou called Geoffrey. So poor old Matilda, having been married off at 8 to a 24-year-old, she's now 26, being married off to a 15-year-old, the heir to the county of Anjou, Geoffrey. And there's something to do with a sprig of... Yes, the badge of the house of Anjou, you, the plantagenista, if you're looking for the beginnings of the plantagenet, we might be
有没有合适的人选可以结婚，也许来自法国王室。有的。安茹，它是诺曼底的邻居，历史上的对手和竞争者，但安茹伯爵领地有一个年轻的继承人叫若弗鲁瓦。所以可怜的玛蒂尔达，8岁时被嫁给一个24岁的人，现在她26岁了，又要被嫁给一个15岁的人，安茹伯爵领地的继承人若弗鲁瓦。这和一枝……有关。是的，安茹家族的徽记，金雀花，如果你在寻找金雀花的起源，我们可能
getting it here. So there's a little clue there as to what might be. So Matilda is married to this guy. Very unhappily. But they have, you know, they clearly have children. They do the job in the end. I mean, Matilda kicks up a fuss. She gets married to him, but within a year, she's back with her dad saying, Dad, do I really have to do this? But she has a little baby boy and she calls him Henry. She does. He a really little red-headed. So little baby Henry Plantaginit. Baby Henry Plantagin. And we may be hearing more of him today and in our next episode.
会在这里找到。所以这里有一个关于可能发生的事情的小线索。玛蒂尔达嫁给了这家伙。婚后很不幸福。但他们（你知道的）显然有孩子。他们最终完成了任务。我是说，玛蒂尔达大发脾气。她嫁给了他，但不到一年，她就回到了父亲身边，说：“爸爸，我真的非得这么做吗？”但她生了一个小男婴，她给他取名叫亨利。她真的这么做了。他是一个真正的小红头发男孩。小亨利·金雀花。小亨利·金雀花。我们今天和下一集可能会听到更多关于他的消息。
We may. We may indeed. So that's the state of play when Henry the first dies. It is. What happens then? He dies very suddenly because he's a... He has a surfeit, doesn't he? He has a surfeit of lampreys.
我们会的。确实会的。这就是亨利一世去世时的局势。确实如此。接下来发生了什么？他死得很突然，因为他……他吃得太多了，不是吗？他吃七鳃鳗过量了。
Because this is an occupational hazard of being a medieval king is that you have surfits and die unexpectedly. I mean, you'd have to pay me to have even one lamprey, I think, let alone a surfeit of them. but the horrible eel-like fish. But anyway, yes, he suddenly takes ill and dies in December 1135. He is in his 60s, but he's a bull of a man. So this is a shock. He's been bestriding the Anglo-Norman realm for more than three decades.
因为这是当一个中世纪国王的职业危险，那就是饮食过量并意外死亡。我的意思是，你得付钱给我，我才会吃哪怕一条七更鳗，更不用说吃过量了。那是一种可怕的鳗鱼般的鱼。但无论如何，是的，他在1135年12月突然生病去世了。他60多岁了，但身体像公牛一样强壮。所以这是一个打击。他已经统治了盎格鲁-诺曼底王国三十多年。
He really, really was, I think. But Matilda, to whom the nobles of England and Normandy, have sworn allegiance more than once by this stage, I mean, I think often the chroniclers and modern historians don't take so seriously the reality of female experience. We're so used to thinking about warfare, the dangers of warfare and so on. But the problem for Matilda in December 1135 is she's had little baby Henry in 1133. She then had little baby Jeffrey in 1134 and nearly died having him. I mean, really seriously, nearly died.
我觉得他真的、真的就是这样。但是玛蒂尔达——此时英格兰和诺曼底的贵族们已经向她不止一次宣誓效忠了——我的意思是，我觉得通常编年史家和现代历史学家并不太认真看待女性经历的现实。我们太习惯于思考战争、战争的危险等等。但对于1135年12月的玛蒂尔达来说，问题在于她在1133年生了小亨利。然后她在1134年生了小若弗鲁瓦，生他的时候差点死掉。我是说，真的非常严重，差点死掉。
In the autumn of 1135, she's pregnant again. She's in the very early stages of pregnancy. And another occupational hazard for medieval women, her husband and her father have fallen out. So she's in Anjou with her husband in the very early stages of pregnancy. She is not in the right place at the right time. And she's going to struggle to get there because she's pregnant. she's not been well, she gets a certain way, she gets into Normandy, just into Normandy,
在1135年秋天，她又怀孕了。她正处于怀孕的早期阶段。而中世纪女性的另一个职业危险是，她的丈夫和父亲闹翻了。所以她和丈夫在安茹，处于怀孕的早期阶段。她没有在正确的时间出现在正确的地点。而且她将很难赶到那里，因为她怀孕了，她身体一直不太好，她走了一段路，进入了诺曼底，刚刚进入诺曼底，
but that's still a long way from the coronation chair. And I suppose to apply the masculine perspective, a woman never looks, from the male point of view, less suited to playing the masculine role of a king than when she's pregnant. That's exactly it. And married, of course, to the Count of Anjou, who the Anglo-Norman baronage are used to thinking of as an enemy. Yeah. So all in all... So it's all tricky. So I suppose in a situation like that where the pregnant queen is not in England, there are opportunities for someone to do a Henry I first and rush off and go to England and get yourself anointed and become the king in situ. And is that what happens? One man among the Anglo-Norman barons has been paying very close attention to the lessons of history, which I know is what we all think.
但那离加冕椅还很远。我想从男性的角度来看，一个女性在怀孕时，看起来是最不适合扮演国王这个男性角色的。完全就是这样。当然，还嫁给了安茹伯爵，盎格鲁-诺曼底的男爵们习惯于将他视为敌人。是的。总而言之……所以这一切都很棘手。所以我想在这样的情况下，怀孕的王后不在英格兰，这为某人效仿亨利一世、冲向英格兰并给自己涂抹圣油、在当地成为国王提供了机会。事情是这样的吗？盎格鲁-诺曼底男爵中的一个人一直在密切关注历史的教训，我知道这是我们所有人的想法。
everyone ought to be doing all the time. The rest of the barons are accompanying Henry's body very slowly back from Normandy to England. And they're having meetings about who could become king, because obviously we don't really want the pregnant woman. And they come up with this idea that Henry, the first nephew, Theobald of Blois, one of their number, might be a good idea. I mean, all due respect to Theo, our Ursulae, producer, but you can't have someone called Theo as king. You can't, can you? I mean, that is a rule, I think. But Theobald has a younger brother called Stephen, who's married to the heiress to Boulogne, which is very handy for getting to England.
每个人都应该一直在做这件事。其余的男爵们正陪着亨利的遗体非常缓慢地从诺曼底返回英格兰。他们正在开会讨论谁可以成为国王，因为显然我们真的不想要这个怀孕的女人。他们想出了一个主意，亨利的外甥，布卢瓦的蒂博，他们中的一员，可能是一个好主意。失敬了，蒂博，我们的制片人厄休拉，但你不能让一个叫蒂博的人当国王。你不能，对吧？我的意思是，这是一个规则，我认为。但蒂博有一个弟弟叫斯蒂芬，他娶了滨海布洛涅的女继承人为妻，这对于去英格兰非常方便。
He has paid attention to what his uncle did when he became king. He jumps on his horse, gets to the coast, gets on a ship, jumps back on a horse, gets himself to Winchester, takes control of the royal treasury, and then has himself crowned and anointed before anyone else knows what's happening. So the sacred oil has seeped into his skin and he is now impregnated. He is impregnated. He is impregnated. This kind of sacramental oil. With kingship. Yeah.
他注意到了他的叔叔当国王时的做法。他跳上马，赶到海岸，上了一艘船，再跳上马，把自己送到温彻斯特，控制了皇家国库，然后在其他人反应过来之前，让自己加冕并被涂抹圣油。所以神圣的油已经渗入他的皮肤，他现在被灌注了。他被灌注了。他被灌注了。这种神圣的油。带有王权。是的。
And so at this point you have two different kinds of royal legitimacy standing in opposition to one another because you have the hereditary principle vested in Matilda. She's been named his heir by the previous king and all the barons have sworn allegiance to her. I suppose some of them have a kind of personal loyalty to Henry and therefore to his daughter too. Absolutely they do. Even though she's this weaker vessel, she's the wrong sex. But yes, Henry has designated her his heir and she does have sons. So the bloodline will continue through Matilda. But on the other hand, you have Stephen, who isn't even the oldest son in his own family.
所以在这一点上，你有两种不同类型的王室合法性彼此对立，因为你有赋予玛蒂尔达的世袭原则。她被前国王指定为继承人，所有男爵都向她宣誓效忠。我想其中一些人对亨利有着某种个人忠诚，因此对他的女儿也是如此。他们绝对是这样的。尽管她是一个较弱的容器，性别不对。但是是的，亨利已经指定她为继承人，她确实有儿子。所以血脉将通过玛蒂尔达延续下去。但另一方面，你有斯蒂芬，他甚至不是他自己家里最大的儿子。
His older brother is still alive. But he has been crowned and anointed. He now is a king, whether you like it or not. So I suppose one solution might be that she stays in Normandy and becomes the kind of the Duchess of Normandy or whatever and Stephen stays in England. But that's not really possible, is it? Because all the barons and so like, they have lands in both Normandy and England. And so they do need someone who can kind of preside over both realms. They do. They need a king, a Duke in Normandy, but they need someone who can provide them with order, with justice, leadership in war. we also have to remember this is a time when
他的哥哥还活着。但他已经加冕并被涂抹圣油。无论你喜欢与否，他现在都是国王。所以我想一个解决方案可能是她留在诺曼底，成为诺曼底女公爵什么的，而斯蒂芬留在英格兰。但那实际上是不可能的，对吧？因为所有的男爵等等，他们在诺曼底和英格兰都有土地。所以他们确实需要一个能够统领这两个王国的人。他们确实需要。他们需要一个国王、一个诺曼底公爵，但他们需要一个能够为他们提供秩序、正义、战争领导力的人。我们还必须记住，这是一个这样的时期：
frontiers between states are exactly that, their frontiers. If you are not defending your frontiers, someone else is going to pour over them with their army. So the idea that you could just leave your lands in Normandy for someone else to look after is not viable. So this is a real problem then? I mean, what happens? How do they resolve this problem? Initially, it looks as though Stephen has won. that kind of decisive seizing the moment and the fact that he's not only been anointed as a king,
国家之间的边界正是如此，它们就是边界。如果你不保卫你的边界，就会有其他人带着军队涌进来。所以认为你可以把你在诺曼底的土地留给别人照顾的想法是不可行的。所以这真的是个问题了？我是说，发生了什么？他们是如何解决这个问题的？最初，看起来斯蒂芬赢了。那类果断抓住时机的做法以及他不仅被涂抹圣油成为国王的事实，
but he looks like he can do the job. He is a man. He can lead in war. He can offer justice. This is what the chroniclers tell us at this point. He takes the throne because he can bring peace. He can bring justice. He fits the job. And so for the first year or so, it looks as though there's a sort of virtuous circle operating in his throne. his favour. Poor old Matilda is off in a castle in the south of Normandy having given birth to her third son. Such bad timing. Such bad timing. But her husband is trying to push into Normandy to try and stake her claim there. But it looks as though England is lost. Even Robert Earl of Gloucester, Matilda's illegitimate half-brother, who's held out for a while trying to resist the idea that Stephen is this irresistible force. He gives in at Easter 1136 and it looks as though Stephen's got it all, but it's not long before it starts going wrong. So is this a reflection of the fact that we haven't really talked about Matilda's character up till now?
而且他看起来能胜任这份工作。他是个男人。他能在战争中领导。他能提供正义。这是编年史家在这个时候告诉我们的。他夺取王位是因为他能带来和平。他能带来正义。他适合这份工作。所以在最初的一年左右，看起来有一种良性循环在对他的王位有利。可怜的玛蒂尔达呆在诺曼底南部的一个城堡里，刚刚生下了她的第三个儿子。时机太差了。时机太差了。但她的丈夫正试图打入诺曼底，以宣示她在那里的权利。但看起来英格兰已经失去了。甚至格洛斯特伯爵罗伯特，玛蒂尔达的私生同父异母兄弟——他坚持了一段时间，试图抵制斯蒂芬是一股不可抗拒的力量的想法——也在1136年復活节屈服了，看起来斯蒂芬已经拥有一切，但没过多久，情况就开始出错了。那么这是否反映了这样一个事实：到目前为止，我们还没有真正谈论过玛蒂尔达的性格？
Is she a very kind of obdurate woman, a determined woman, someone who's not prepared to let this? Matilda is not going to let her inheritance go. She won't let it go for her own sake. She is the daughter of Henry I. Of course, but little baby Henry. But she is the mother of sons. She's had to marry. and his little red face.
她是一个非常顽固的女人、一个坚定的女人、一个不准备让这一切……的女人吗？玛蒂尔达不会放弃她的继承权。她不会为了她自己而放弃。她是亨利一世的女儿。当然，还有小亨利。但她是几个儿子的母亲。她不得不结婚。
She's had to marry this plantagenet youngster that she didn't want to have anything to do with, but she's done it in order to get these sons, and she is not going to let their inheritance go. It's quite hard to get a sense of the detail of Matilda's character with all these women. The chroniclers don't really give us thumbnail sketches in the same way. She is very, very tough. Even though, I mean, it's really interesting. If you read The Chronicles, they're almost trying.
和那个她不想与之有任何关系的年轻金雀花人结婚，但她这么做是为了得到这些儿子，她绝不会放弃他们的继承权。要了解玛蒂尔达性格的细节是相当困难的，对所有这些女性都是如此。编年史家并没有真正以同样的方式给我们提供简短的素描。她非常、非常坚强。尽管，我的意思是，这真的很有趣。如果你读编年史，他们几乎在试图
not to mention her. There are two chronicles at this point, the Gesta Stefani, which is the deeds of Stephen, so we know who the hero is there, he tries not to mention her. He says the Countess of Anjou or the Earl of Gloucester's sister. He doesn't really want to let her on stage. Certainly not calling her the Empress. Exactly. Whereas William of Malmesbury, who's much more sympathetic, his hero is Robert of Gloucester, her half-brother. So we get glimpses and Matilda around the edges, but every glimpse we get shows us how. How tough she is. Right.
不提及她。当时有两个编年史，《斯蒂芬的事迹》（Gesta Stephani），所以我们知道谁是那里的英雄，他尽量不提她。他说安茹伯爵夫人或格洛斯特伯爵的妹妹。他真的不想让她上台。当然不叫她女皇。正是如此。而威廉·马姆斯伯里（William of Malmesbury）则更有同情心，他的英雄是格洛斯特伯爵罗伯特，她的同父异母兄弟。所以我们从边缘看到了玛蒂尔达的吉光片羽，但我们得到的每一个吉光片羽都向我们展示了她是多么坚强。没错。
So you can judge her by her actions. And her actions essentially are to aim not just to secure Normandy, but to claim the throne of England. By 1139, so we are four years into Stephen's reign now, it is clear that Stephen is struggling to get any kind of foothold in Normandy. Matilda and Geoffrey are doing well there. And that's going to be a structural problem for him, because if he can only claim half the Anglo-Norman realm,
所以你可以通过她的行动来判断她。她的行动本质上不仅是为了确保诺曼底的安全，也是为了夺取英格兰的王位。到了1139年，也就是斯蒂芬统治的第四年，很明显斯蒂芬在诺曼底很难立足。玛蒂尔达和若弗鲁瓦在那里的进展顺利。这对他的结构性问题，因为如果他只能宣称拥有盎格鲁-诺曼底王国的一半，
He's going to struggle to get all the barons to follow him. But Matilda, in 1139, does the key thing. She gets herself to England because that's where she's going to stay. So how does she get a foothold there? It's a brave move. So we can say she's brave as well as tough. We can say she's very brave. She and Robert of Gloucester, her half-brother, take ship for England and they land.
他将很难让所有的男爵都跟随他。但是玛蒂尔达在1139年做了关键的一件事。她把自己送到了英格兰，因为那是她将要呆的地方。那么她是如何在那里站稳脚跟的？这是一个勇敢的举动。所以我们可以说她既勇敢又坚强。我们可以说她非常勇敢。她和她的同父异母兄弟格洛斯特伯爵罗伯特乘船前往英格兰并登陆。
They don't hit a rock. They don't hit a rock. First victory. She's done better than her brother already. She lands at Arendel in Sussex And this is very canny Because they've only got to small bodyguard with them But Arndal Castle is held by
他们没有撞上暗礁。他们没有撞上暗礁。第一场胜利。她已经比她的兄弟做得更好了。她在苏塞克斯的阿伦德尔登陆，这非常精明，因为他们随身携带的只有一小支保镖队伍，但阿伦德尔城堡由
Matilda's widowed stepmother Adeliza of Louvain Who's the same age as her This young woman that her father had married After her brother died Adelaiza's remarried But Matilda and Adelisa do know each other Of old
玛蒂尔达的寡妇继母鲁万的阿德丽莎（Adeliza of Louvain）控制。她和她同龄。这是在她哥哥死后她父亲娶的年轻女子。阿德丽莎再婚了。但玛蒂尔达和阿德丽莎确实认识。老交情了。
They seem to have a lot of respect for each other And Adeliza lets Matilda into the castle. Robert of Gloucester spirits himself away to his stronghold in Bristol. But Stephen has now got a problem. Matilda's in the country. She's in a castle with the ex-Queen, the Queen Dowager. Is he going to besiege them? Is he going to try to capture them? What's that going to look like? Here's a moment where being a woman can actually help you. If she was a man, then all bets are off. It's war. But she's a woman. Is Stephen really going to besiege? So there's a kind of hint of she'll Chivalry, absolutely. Stephen is not going to do his image as King any good if he is seen to be treating two royal women without due deference, without due respect.
她们似乎对彼此有很多尊重，阿德丽莎让玛蒂尔达进入了城堡。格洛斯特伯爵罗伯特悄悄回到了他在布里斯托尔的据点。但斯蒂芬现在有了麻烦。玛蒂尔达在这个国家。她和前王后、太后在一座城堡里。他要围攻她们吗？他要试图俘虏她们吗？那会是什么样子？这是一个女性身份实际上可以帮到你的时刻。如果她是个男人，那么一切皆有可能。这就是战争。但她是个女人。斯蒂芬真的会围攻吗？所以有一种关于骑士精神的暗示，绝对是的。如果斯蒂芬被视为没有给予两位王室女性应有的尊重和敬意，这对他的国王形象没有任何好处。
So it's a little bit like in the series we did on 1970s Britain, Harold Wilson wondering how he was going to deal with Margaret Thatcher at Prime Minister's question time. In a very vague kind of way. It's not a bad analogy. And one of the criticisms that is leveled at Stephen is that he's too nice. He struggles to land the killer blow. He's good at decisive action. I mean, he's next to the throne. I mean, he's not that nice.
所以这有点像我们在关于70年代英国的系列节目中，哈罗德·威尔逊想知道他将如何在首相问答时间应对玛格丽特·柴尔德。用一种非常模糊的方式。这不是一个糟糕的比喻。针对斯蒂芬的批评之一是他太好了。他很难给出致命一击。他擅长果断行动。我的意思是，他离王位很近。我的意思是，他没那么好。
He's good at that kind of decisive action. But when it comes to the iron fist. To capturing and killing women. Capturing, killing women. Even capturing and killing some of his male opponents. The killer blow sometimes. So this is the lesson of history. Don't be weak if you're a medieval king.
他很擅长那种果断的行动。但说到铁腕统治，说到抓捕和杀害女性——抓捕、杀害女性，甚至抓捕和杀害他的一些男性对手——往往缺少了致命一击。所以这就是历史的教训：如果你是一个中世纪的国王，千万不要软弱。
Exactly. So essentially the consequence of this is that civil war breaks out and this is what comes to be called the anarchy the time when Christ and his saints slept and it rages and rages and this was always my favorite period when I was a child in studying medieval history because it's where the terrible tortures come in because the the barons would steal wayfarers and they would put knotted ropes around their heads and slowly tightened them until they handed over their money, or they would put cages with rats on the stomach, and the rats would gnaw through the stomach again until they revealed where their money was. And so this for me as a child was the single most interesting thing about the anarchy. You were doing horrible histories before horrible histories existed. I'm suspecting that you were going to have a slightly different perspective on this,
没错。所以这带来的实质性后果就是内战爆发，而这就是后来被称为“无政府时期”的时代，也就是“基督和他的圣徒们沉睡的时代”。这场内战持续不断，而这正是我小时候研究中世纪历史时最喜欢的时期，因为这里面有各种可怕的酷刑。当时的男爵们会劫掠过往的旅客，把打结的绳子套在他们头上慢慢勒紧，直到他们交出钱财；或者把装有老鼠的笼子放在他们肚子上，老鼠会啃噬他们的肚子，直到他们说出钱藏在哪里。因此，对我小时候来说，这是关于“无政府时期”最有趣的一点。在《糟糕的历史》诞生之前，你就在做《糟糕的历史》了。我猜你对此会有稍微不同的看法。
and that there are actually more interesting things to say about the anarchy than the rats on the stomach. I'm not sure there are more interesting things. In a way, on a par. On a par with the rats. And actually, it's a really good point because it shows us why you need a king. Of course. Because often... Can't have people going around putting rats on people's stomach. Exactly. And that's what the barons will do if left to their own devices. And they will do it not just because they are aiming for power by any means necessary, but they're also trying to defend themselves. This is always the problem. If you're a medieval baron, yes, you can go around putting rats on people's stomachs. But if a bigger baron comes along, what's he going to do to you?
关于无政府状态，实际上有比肚子上的老鼠更有趣的事情可说。我不确定是不是真有更有趣的事情。从某种程度上说，这与老鼠不相上下。与老鼠并驾齐驱。实际上，这是一个非常好的观点，因为它向我们展示了为什么你需要一个国王。当然。因为经常……不能让人到处在别人的肚子上放老鼠。正是如此。如果任由男爵们自行其是，他们就会这么做。他们这么做不仅是因为他们不择手段地谋求权力，也是因为他们在试图保护自己。这始终是个问题。如果你是一个中世纪的男爵，是的，你可以到处在别人的肚子上放老鼠。但是，如果一个更强大的男爵出现了，他会对你做什么呢？
So this is why anarchy is terrifying. So that's bad. And the other famous thing that happens in the anarchy is people rushing around in snow wearing nightdresses. So what's going on with that? We will get to that because that's one, again, one of Matilda's very bravest moments. Even her enemies grudgingly admit that she's brave at that point. But this is to do with the key, really the pivotal part of the anarchy, because it is 19 years of of slugging at each other. chaotic civil war. But the pivotal point is 1140, 1141. So it comes pretty quickly after Matilda has arrived in England. Robert of Gloucester by now is her champion. He's her general. She can't fight in a battle. But Robert of Gloucester is going to lead her army.
所以这就是为什么无政府状态是可怕的。所以这很糟糕。无政府状态中发生的另一件著名的事情是人们穿着睡裙在雪地里跑来跑去。这到底是怎么回事？我们会讲到这一点，因为这再次体现了玛蒂尔达最勇敢的时刻之一。即使是她的敌人在那一刻也勉强承认她是勇敢的。但这与关键所在有关，也就是无政府状态的转折点，因为这是长达19年的相互厮杀。混乱的内战。但转折点是1140年、1141年。所以这发生在玛蒂尔达抵达英格兰后不久。格洛斯特的罗伯特现在是她的捍卫者。他是她的将军。她不能上战场。但格洛斯特的罗伯特将领导她的军队。
of that that she could ride out in the kind of, you know, Queen Elizabeth at Tilbury style in armour. But even Queen Elizabeth at Tilbury, the Armada isn't here yet. I mean, yes, she can do the figurehead bit, but you don't want her in the battlefield. She can't fight, but also she might get captured. And so again, being female does have its advantages in some ways, because what happens winter of 1140, 1141 is that there is a siege at Lincoln. King Stephen is. besieging Lincoln Castle. He's surprised by the army of Robert of Gloucester. A battle ensues in February 1141 and he is captured. Now up till this point, the fact that he's been anointed, that impregnated with kingship has been the ace in his hand. But once he's a prisoner, suddenly the balance has shifted. So suddenly, Matilda's quids in. God is not with Stephen anymore. This is Matilda's moment. She is going to.
她可以像伊丽莎白女王在蒂尔贝里那样，身穿盔甲骑马出行。但即使是蒂尔贝里的伊丽莎白女王，无敌舰队当时也还没到。我的意思是，是的，她可以扮演精神领袖的角色，但你不会想让她上战场。她不会打仗，而且她可能会被俘虏。所以再次说明，身为女性在某些方面确实有优势，因为在1140年到1141年的冬天，林肯发生了一场围城战。斯蒂芬国王正在。围攻林肯城堡。他被格洛斯特罗伯特的军队突袭了。1141年2月发生了一场战役，他被俘了。到现在为止，他被涂抹圣油、被赋予王权一直是他的王牌。但一旦他成为阶下囚，局势突然就发生了转变。所以突然之间，玛蒂尔达占了上风。上帝不再保佑斯蒂芬了。这是玛蒂尔达的时刻。她将要。
to step forward and become queen. And so she advances to Westminster to prepare for her coronation, the point at which her queenship will take effect. And so that happens? And what is the impact of that on her legitimacy? It doesn't happen. That's the big problem. The big, biggest pivotal moment in the whole story is that once she has reached Westminster in 1141, suddenly, and you'll be amazed to hear this, both medieval chroniclers and modern historians say, ah, yes, but a previously undetected character flaw starts letting her down. It turns out, in fact, one of the chroniclers says, puts it very well, the guest is Stefani says,
向前迈进并成为女王。因此，她前往威斯敏斯特为加冕做准备，这是她的女王身份将正式生效的时刻。事情真的发生了吗？这对她的合法性有什么影响？并没有发生。这就是最大的问题。整个故事中最重大、最关键的时刻是，一旦她在1141年到达威斯敏斯特，突然间，你会惊奇地听到，中世纪的编年史家和现代历史学家都说，啊，是的，但是一个以前未被发现的性格缺陷开始让她失望了。事实证明，正如其中一位编年史家所说，斯蒂芬的访客说，
she at once put on an extremely arrogant demeanour instead of the modest gait and bearing proper to the gentle sex and began to walk and speak and do all things more stiffly and more haughtily than she had been won't. So she's behaving like a king? She is behaving like a king. What else is she supposed to do? She's supposed to take command. Her father was the lion of justice, inflexible in his authority.
她立刻表现出极其傲慢的姿态，而不是温顺性别应有的谦逊步伐和风度，开始以比以往更僵硬、更傲慢的方式行走、说话和做所有事情。所以她的行为像个国王？她的行为确实像个国王。她还能怎么做？她本该接管权力。她的父亲是正义之狮，在权威面前毫不妥协。
But the man who thinks he's putting her on the throne, which is Stephen's younger brother, Henry, Bishop of Winchester, thinks he's going to be the power behind the throne. He thinks Matilda should be doing exactly what he tells her to. She's not having any of that. She is not having any of that. So why does she not? get anointed. Because at the point where she is waiting for her coronation, Henry Bishop of
但是那个认为自己能把她推上王位的人——也就是斯蒂芬的弟弟、温彻斯特主教亨利——认为自己会成为王位背后的权力操纵者。他认为玛蒂尔达应该完全按照他的吩咐去做。她才不吃这一套。她根本不吃这一套。那么她为什么不接受受膏呢？因为在她等待加冕的时候，亨利，温彻斯特的
Winchester, the one who's got her to that point, he thinks, and the Londoners both decide we're not happy with this. The Londoners pour out of the city, drive Matilda away from Westminster. She has to flee again. Her moment passes. Her moment passes. And not only that, but then at Winchester, another battle happens or another skirmish happens where Robert of Gloucester is taken prisoner. At that point, you've got to do a prisoner swap because she can't do without her brother to lead her troops. Robert for Stephen, Stephen's back in play, the whole thing starts off again. Couldn't she just find any old bishop? And, you know, I mean, any cathedral would do, just get, or Abby, and just get anointed. You'd think, wouldn't you? But the
主教——那个把她带到这一步的人——和伦敦市民都决定我们对此很不满意。伦敦市民涌出城市，将玛蒂尔达赶出威斯敏斯特。她不得不再次逃跑。她的时刻错过了。她的时刻错过了。不仅如此，随后在温彻斯特又发生了一场战役或一场小规模冲突，格洛斯特的罗伯特被俘虏了。在那一刻，你必须进行俘虏交换，因为没有她哥哥来统帅军队是行不通的。用罗伯特换斯蒂芬，斯蒂芬重新掌权，一切又回到了起点。她就不能随便找个老主教吗？你知道，我的意思是，任何大教堂都可以，只要找个，或者修道院，然后接受受膏就行了。你以为会这样，对吧？但是
difficulty is any old bishop, will that do really? I mean, it's better than nothing. Yeah. If you and I had been there, Tom, she might have had some better advice. Great shame. Part of the problem is even getting to a cathedral because the white cloak and the nighty in the snow is Oxford. In the winter of 1142, she's under siege in Oxford and she manages to slip out through the snow across the frozen river, seven miles in the snow wearing a white cloak for camouflage. She is brave physically as well as in every other way. but she just can't.
难点在于，随便找个老主教，真的行吗？我的意思是，总比没有强。对。如果你和我当时也在场，汤姆，她可能会得到一些更好的建议。真是遗憾。部分问题在于甚至都很难到达大教堂，因为那个穿着白斗篷和睡衣在雪地里奔跑的故事发生在牛津。在1142年的冬天，她被困在牛津遭遇围城，她设法在雪地里穿过结冰的河面溜了出去，穿着一件白斗篷作为掩护，在雪地里走了七英里。她不仅在各方面都表现得极为勇敢，而且体力上也同样坚强。但她就是做不到。
Stephen won't land the killer blow and she can't. Okay, so 19 years of anarchy to cut to the chase. How does this anarchy end? And what does it mean for Stephen, for Matilda and for, well, no longer little baby Henry Plantagenet. I mean, he's kind of grown up by now. What we're looking at is Matilda's judgment here. Yes, she was indomitable, but no. she wasn't inflexibly arrogant because by the late 1140s she sees there's no way through for her.
斯蒂芬不肯给她致命一击，她也无能为力。好吧，为了直奔主题，经历了19年的无政府状态。这场无政府状态是怎么结束的？这对于斯蒂芬、玛蒂尔达以及——嗯，不再是小婴儿的亨利·金雀花——意味着什么？我的意思是，他现在已经长大了。我们在这里看到的是玛蒂尔达的判断力。是的，她坚韧不拔，但不是。她并不是顽固而傲慢的，因为到了1140年代后期，她看出自己已经走不通了。
She is not going to be able to unite the Anglo-Norman barons around female leadership, but she has handily provided someone who might represent the future and that is her son Henry. Although he's young still, he is proving himself to be a very formidable ruler by this point in Normandy, isn't he? He is. He is recognised. His father has managed, more or less, to conquer Normandy in the name of his wife and his son in 1150, at which point Henry is, what are we talking, 16, 17, he is recognised as Duke of Normandy. He then comes to England. And by this stage, it's clear that even the people who still support Stephen as King are beginning to talk about Henry as the lawful heir. And so there is scope there for a deal? The deal is Stephen will continue to rule, but when Stephen dies, Henry Matilda's son will inherit. The grandson of Henry I will become Henry II. And that is the deal that's done in 1153 at the Treaty of Winchester.
她无法将盎格鲁-诺曼底男爵团结在女性领导人周围，但她巧妙地培养了一个能够代表未来的人，那就是她的儿子亨利。尽管他还年轻，但在这个时候，他在诺曼底已经证明自己是一个非常令人生畏的统治者了，不是吗？是的。他得到了认可。他的父亲在1150年以妻子和儿子的名义，多多少少征服了诺曼底，当时亨利大概——我们算算——16、17岁，他被承认为诺曼底公爵。然后他来到了英格兰。到这个时候，很明显，甚至那些仍然支持斯蒂芬为王的人也开始谈论亨利为合法的继承人。所以这里有达成交易的空间？交易的内容是斯蒂芬将继续统治，但当斯蒂芬去世后，玛蒂尔达的儿子亨利将继承王位。亨利一世的外孙将成为亨利二世。这就是1153年通过《温彻斯特条约》达成的交易。
So Henry the 2nd we will be coming to in our next episode. We will. Because, of course, he has a very famous and feisty wife in the form of Eleanor of Aquitaine. and we'll be talking about her. But before we end, Stephen dies, Henry succeeds him to become Henry the second of England. What happens to Matilda? Matilda stays in Normandy. In a sense, she's in retirement.
所以亨利二世我们将在下一集中探讨。我们会的。因为，当然，他有一个非常著名且争强好胜的妻子，那就是阿基坦的埃莉诺。我们将讨论她。但在我们结束之前，斯蒂芬去世了，亨利继位成为英格兰的亨利二世。玛蒂尔达怎么样了？玛蒂尔达留在了诺曼底。从某种意义上说，她退休了。
In a sense, she's taken up a very much approved role now of spending a lot of her time at an abbey, of which she's a particular patron. but she is the elder stateswoman of her son's regime. He looks to her for advice. So she's a kind of matriarchal figure? She's a matriarchal figure. He doesn't always take her advice. When she warns against making Thomas Beckett, Archbishop of Canterbury, he doesn't listen to her.
从某种意义上说，她现在担任了一个备受赞誉的角色，把大量时间花在了一座她特别资助的修道院里。但她是她儿子政权的资深女政治家。他遇事会向她征求意见。所以她是一种家长式的人物？她是一个家长式的人物。他并不总是听取她的建议。当她警告不要让托马斯·贝克特担任坎特伯雷大主教时，他并没有听她的。
Should have listened to money. But she is this fount of wisdom. But in such a way, in such an acceptably female way, that if you go to Ruan Cathedral, where her remains ended up in the end. There is an epitaph to her carved into the wall. And what this epitaph says is, great by birth, greater by marriage, greatest in her offspring, here lies the daughter, wife, and mother of Henry. Okay, so she is defined by her male relations.
本该听她的。但她是智慧的源泉。但这种方式，是以一种让人完全能够接受的女性方式，如果你去鲁昂大教堂——她的遗体最终安息的地方。墙上刻着她的墓志铭。这个墓志铭写道：出身高贵，因婚姻而更高贵，因后代而最伟大，这里长眠着亨利的女儿、妻子和母亲。好吧，所以她是通过她与男性的关系来被定义的。
And just before we end, can I ask, does she serve as a kind of object lesson? to future generations, is her attempt to make herself a kind of regnant queen recollected? Or is that not influential on how people come to think about the possibility of a female monarch? It certainly is remembered, but it faces in two directions, her example, because in one sense, it is clear that a woman can transmit the right to inherit the crown of England. Her son has become king. She's the daughter of a king and she's the mother of a king. So claims through women operate in England and all future kings are descended from her. But her attempt to claim the throne for herself resulted in 19 years when Christ and his saints slept. So the example it gives
在我们结束之前，我可以问一下，她是否可以作为给后代的一个警示案例？她试图让自己成为某种女王的行为是否被人们铭记？或者这并没有对人们对女性君主可能性的看法产生影响？它确实被人们铭记，但她的榜样具有双重影响，因为从某种意义上说，很明显女性可以传递继承英格兰王冠的权力。她的儿子成了国王。她是一个国王的女儿，也是一个国王的母亲。因此，通过女性获得王位的权利在英格兰发挥了作用，所有未来的国王都是她的后代。但她为自己争夺王位的尝试导致了基督和圣徒沉睡的19年。所以它给出的例子
of female rule is a deeply alarming and worrying one. Okay. So thank you, Helen. And we will be back next time, as I said, with Eleanor of Aquitaine, the wife of Henry II, Matilda's son, and she will be our second she-wolf. So I hope you enjoyed this first episode of our new Super Souraway mini-series. And if you would like to see The Rest and you're not a member of The Restless History Club, you can go to the Restless History.com, sign up there for this. and a host of sensational other benefits. Hi everybody, we are back with another absolutely colossal update
关于女性统治，这是一个非常令人震惊和担忧的例子。好的。谢谢你，海伦。正如我所说，我们下次会带着阿基坦的埃莉诺回归，她是玛蒂尔达的儿子亨利二世的妻子，她将是我们的第二只母狼。所以希望大家喜欢我们新的“历史余音”迷你系列的第一集。如果你想收听其余内容，又还不是“历史余音”俱乐部的会员，你可以前往therestlesshistory.com，在那里注册即可获得本集内容。
about the rest is history festival. Well, it's massive. So on the 4th and 5th of July, we will be at Hampton Court Palace. We have a weekend of brilliant talks, live music, exclusive access to historic Royal Palace's collections. And yes, Dominic, most exciting of all, this is the thing I have been pushing for, and I'm so looking forward to it.
以及一系列轰动性的其他福利。大家好，我们带着关于“历史余音”节的另一个极其重大的更新回归了
We have medieval combat. a terrifying, brutal, yet completely thrilling sport. It is going to be an unforgettable two days. It is indeed. And at the core of the festival of these talks, we've got some more talks to add to the lineup. So I will be talking to the brilliant Tudor historian Tracy Borman about the secrets of the six wives of Henry VIII.
关于“历史余音”节。嗯，这规模太宏大了。所以在7月4日和5日，我们将来到汉普顿宫。我们将迎来一个充满精彩演讲、现场音乐以及独家参观英国皇家宫殿收藏的周末。是的，多米尼克，最令人兴奋的是，这是我一直极力推动的事情，我太期待了。
I'll be talking to a friend of the show and Irish National Treasure, Paul Rouse, about whether there is an alternative universe in which islands could have remained. part of the United Kingdom. We'll be talking to Katya Hoyer about Weimar, Germany, and in particular, the town of Weimar through history, and Professor Adam Smith will be telling the story of America through three presidents. And on top of all that, I'll be doing a special event with Ian Hizlop about the history of satire. And I will be on stage with Mary Beard, and we will be
我们将有中世纪格斗表演。这是一项惊险刺激、残酷但又完全令人兴奋的运动。这将是难忘的两天。确实如此。而作为这些演讲的核心，我们还有一些新的演讲要加入阵容。所以我将与杰出的都铎王朝历史学家特雷西·博尔曼一起讨论亨利八世六位妻子的秘密。
talking about just how strange, just how alien, just how different to us Rome was, or maybe it wasn't. I will be talking to Helen Castor about Elizabeth I'll be discussing whether she truly was England's greatest ruler, or maybe whether that title should still be claimed by Athelstan. I will be talking to Ali Ansari about all things Persian, with Dan Jackson about the pit of death. And I will be talking to friend of the show, Willie Dalrymer. about the links between ancient India and Greece and Rome. Absolutely incredible scenes. And of course on both days, Tom and I will be on stage doing a show together as well.
我将与节目的朋友兼爱尔兰国宝保罗·劳斯讨论，是否存在一个平行宇宙，让爱尔兰能够继续留在联合王国之内。我们将与卡蒂亚·霍耶讨论魏玛德国，特别是历史上魏玛镇的故事，亚当··史密斯教授将通过三位总统讲述美国的故事。除此之外，我将与伊恩·希斯洛普一起做一个关于讽刺历史的特别活动。我将与玛丽·比尔德同台，我们将
So on the first day, we'll be answering all our club members' questions. And then to close the festival, we will do a definitive ranking of the all-time top friends of the show. So lots to look forward to. And beyond that, there is so much else that will be happening across the weekend. So think of it as the ultimate summer history hangout. And your tickets will give you full access to explore the great Tudor Palace of Hampton Court and indeed the Royal Tennis Court. So that would be very exciting. There will be food and drink fit for a king, which sounds very enticing.
讨论罗马是多么奇怪、多么疏离、与我们多么不同，或者也许并非如此。我将与海伦·卡斯托讨论伊丽莎白一世，我将探讨她是否真的是英格兰最伟大的统治者，或者这个称号是否仍然应该归于阿塞尔斯坦。我将与阿里·安萨里讨论所有波斯相关的话题，与丹·杰克逊讨论死亡之坑。我还将与节目的朋友威利·达尔林普尔讨论古印度与希腊和罗马之间的联系。绝对令人难以置信的场面。当然，在这两天里，我和汤姆也会同台为大家带来一场表演。
I picture the very glamorous people that are our club members and their summer garb. They're on the lawn at Hampton Court Palace. They're chatting about history and delightful surroundings, sipping on a refreshing gin and tonic. And it's probably the most civilized festival there's ever been. I mean, that's what I imagine anyway. Just a reminder, the tickets are exclusive to club members. And if you are not a member, now is the perfect time to join. So head over to the rest ishistory.com to sign up and grab your tickets.
所以在第一天，我们将回答所有俱乐部成员的问题。然后在闭幕时，我们将对历代以来的节目挚友进行一次权威排名。所以有很多值得期待的事情。除此之外，整个周末还将发生很多其他事情。所以把它想象成终极的夏季历史大聚会吧。你的门票将让你全面探索伟大的都铎宫殿汉普顿宫，以及皇家网球场。这将非常令人兴奋。那里将有适合国王享用的美食和美酒，听起来非常诱人。
And of course, have access to a whole range of supplementary benefits. benefits. Once you have signed up to the restishistory.com, all you do then is log into the members area and you select festival and it's all very obvious. But you know what? There is a twist. If you do this, you will be entered into a genuinely unbelievable prize draw. And that prize draw, if you win, you and three other people, it's like the golden ticket in Charlie in the Chocolate Factory, because you will be given the chance to be upgraded to the experience and the premium experience will give you, among other things, unlimited food and drink for free all day.
我能想象到我们俱乐部成员那些极其迷人的身影和他们的夏装。他们在汉普顿宫的草坪上。他们在迷人的环境中谈论历史，品尝着清爽的金汤力。这可能是史上最文明的音乐节了。我的意思是，反正我是这么想象的。再次提醒，门票是俱乐部成员专属的。如果你还不是会员，现在是加入的最佳时机。所以请前往therestishistory.com注册并抢购你的门票。
Do not miss it. Can't wait to see you there. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
当然，还可以享受全套的附加福利。一旦你在therestishistory.com注册，你要做的就是登录会员区，然后选择“节日”，一切都非常显然而易见。但你知道吗？还有一个转折点。如果你这样做了，你将有机会参加一个真正令人难以置信的抽奖活动。那个抽奖活动，如果你赢了，你和其他三个人，就像《查理和巧克力工厂》里的金色门票一样，因为你将获得升级到贵宾体验的机会，其中将为你提供全天免费无限量供应的美食和饮品等福利。千万不要错过。迫不及待地想在那里见到大家。本期节目暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。